- Après la tempête, c'est
l'état de choc à New York :
plus de 40 morts dans quatre
États; Ida a été dévastatrice
et meurtrière.
Jamais la ville n'avait connu
de pires intempéries :
80 mm de pluie en une heure,
un métro submergé et
des passagers pris de court,
du jamais-vu.
"C'est le réveil le plus
brutal qu'on pouvait avoir",
dit un Bill de Blasio
dépassé par les événements.
Ici, dans le quartier
de Queens, trois personnes
sont mortes noyées
dans leur sous-sol.
Non loin de là, Raoul Batista
nous montre les dégâts chez lui.
La veille, le frigidaire servait
de barque dans son sous-sol.
"J'ai tout perdu, dit-il,
mais ça aurait pu être pire,
car le matériel peut toujours
être remplacé."
L'état d'urgence a été décrété
dans tout l'État de New York
par la nouvelle gouverneure,
qui venait à peine d'entrer
en fonction.
"Nous avions déployé
les ressources additionnelles
hier matin, dit-elle, mais
on ne pensait pas que les chutes
du Niagara allaient se déverser
sur nous."
Le New Jersey est l'État
le plus touché avec 23 morts,
dont deux qui étaient pris
dans leurs voitures.
En Pennsylvanie, des pompiers
venus porter secours ont été
à leur tour pris par le déluge.
"Les pompiers sont devenus
des sinistrés, dit-il, et ont dû
être transportés à l'hôpital."
"Nous faisons face
à une nouvelle réalité",
lance Bill de Blasio, faisant
référence aux changements
climatiques.
150 000 personnes sont toujours
privées d'électricité.
Raoul Batista, lui, se demande
comment il va payer son loyer :
tous ses outils de travail
ont été détruits.
Le président américain a voulu
être rassurant : "Nous sommes là
pour vous", dit-il, promettant
que ceux qui sont les plus
touchés par Ida recevront
l'aide nécessaire.
Les gens continuent de déloger
leur sous-sol. Les scientifiques
avertissent que les tempêtes
vont devenir de plus en pl